[Musique]
Geneviève Tellier allait Castonguay et
Christian Dufour qui est en chemin on
lui souhaite de nous de se joindre à
nous on commence bien sûr avec ce
dernier heure en fin d'après-midi
Diplomat chinois finalement qui a été
expulsé du pays je fais entendre tout de
suite les réactions de Michael Chang le
député qui avait fait l'objet de
pression de la Chine et d'intimidation
les cotons
j'espère que cette décision de le
gouvernement aujourd'hui donne un clair
message clair au régime autorité
aérienne que c'est pas c'est unique
acceptable de de menacer les les
citoyens canadiens ici au Canada
Zaho le diplomate en question à 5 jours
pour faire ses valises et quitter
Geneviève Tellier devant la question
c'est bon le gouvernement fait-il le
choix un d'agir 2 il y aura des repas
chinoises
oui je pense que c'est ça le point
principal c'est ça ce que le
gouvernement avait le choix d'agir ben
si il réfléchissait aux conséquences
peut-être qu'il y aurait pas voulu agir
tant que ça mais d'un point de vue
politique avec la pression qu'on voyait
à Ottawa puis ça partait pas sur cet
angle là on allait marteler ça pendant
des jours alors ça a été une façon pour
le gouvernement d'y aller assez
rapidement et puis dire bon on est
d'accord on l'excuse on l'excuse expulse
par contre oui je m'attends à une
riposte la part de la Chine je pense que
c'est pas conseillé d'aller en Chine en
ce moment faudrait faire attention et je
me demande l'ampleur de la riposte aussi
qui va y avoir la dernière fois il y
avait eu l'emprisonnement de deux
Canadiens les deux bricoles comme on les
appelle alors ce qu'on va y avoir une
réponse similaire ou bien ça va être une
riposte plutôt diplomatique ça veut dire
vous en exclusive vous expulsez un
diplomate donc on va faire la même chose
qu'on va expulser un diplomate canadien
si ce n'est que ça ça sera possible mais
je m'attends à une réponse chinoise
parce que lors de l'arrestation de
mainguenzu vous l'avez dit Geneviève on
les Chinois avaient pris les deux
mycours puis ça avait été ça n'a pas été
oeil pour œil dans pour dans ça avait
été le double et d'un des conditions
extrêmement difficiles de détention Alec
on le savait mais malgré ce risque là on
avait plus le choix comme dit Geneviève
non on l'avait plus le choix je pense
qu'on fallait envoyer un message non
seulement à la Chine mais à tous les
autres pays autoritaires qui pourraient
voir un peu le laxisme au Canada si on
commence à laisser des diplomates qui
intimides de la famille de député de
parlementaire comme ça de manière
impunément sur les laisser ici il y
aurait effectivement une tentation de
reproduire ce schéma là mais le problème
c'est que c'est la Chine et la Chine
c'est toujours compliqué c'est on ne
suit plus depuis longtemps en Chine les
règles écrites et non écrites de la
diplomatie internationale la réponse de
la Chine normalement devrait être
d'expulsée un diplomate canadien
représailles mais la Chine très
imprévisible elle peut décider qu'elle
ça représente c'est on a on augmente les
inspections sur le port canadien puis
soudainement se trouve toutes sortes de
petites canadien et puis il y a un
embargo qui est créé on pourrait décider
que le canot le Canadien ne respecte
plus les règles chinois et hop on a plus
de canola Canadiens qui s'exporte vers
les États-Unis donc il y avait une
crainte du côté des entreprises
canadiennes qui font en faire en Chine
que la réponse chinoise connaissent pas
portionner moi ce qu'on dit c'est que le
fait qu'on ait pris quelques jours
supplémentaires on a dialogué avec ici
la Chine ils ont une réponse écrite très
musclée mais que ça devrait bien aller
c'est comme ça qu'on m'a dit ça ça
devrait bien aller on pense que la
riposte doit être proportionnelle et
qu'on soit capable de vivre avec la
réponse et donc aujourd'hui on a
enclenché l'étape suivante puis ils en
ont quand même vu d'autres la machine
diplomatique chinoise laissons quand
même habitués très bien on a Christian
Paula il va il va peut-être s'en venir
d'ici la famille nous on continue retour
sur le congrès libéral parce que tout ce
temps là il y avait un congrès libéral
en fin de semaine monsieur Trudeau dans
un discours avant de s'envoler pour
Londres dit je suis là pour rester on va
écouter un tout petit extrait et on
revient
sur
moment
of my life to leader future
[Applaudissements]
n'en parlait rapidement la semaine
dernière Alec quand quelqu'un dit ça
sera l'honneur de ma vie c'est ça qu'on
apprenne extra en anglais d'ailleurs
c'était plus c'était plus passionné que
celui en français l'honneur de ma vie
que de mener cette lutte contre
quelqu'un qui veut détruire tout ce dont
je crois
il y a plus de doute là il sera là à
moins de moins qu'on voit mal les choses
avec
non et c'était Trudeau efficace qu'on a
vu jeudi soir au congrès libéral celui
des campagnes électorales celui qui aime
se battre j'étais un Trudeau semble
avoir plus de plaisir à faire campagne
qui a dirigé parfois on le regarde aller
pendant qu'il est au gouvernement puis
on se dit ce qui est encore le feu on
dirait pas qu'il l'a en lui c'est
souvent hésitant prends pas toujours des
décisions très rapidement mais en
campagne électorale ça reste un atout
certain pour la partie libérale sa
capacité à communiquer avec les gens
être près des gens à aimer faire
campagne ça se sent et donc c'est se
Justin Trudeau là qui était jeudi devant
ces députés alors oui il aura clairement
envoyé le message je vais être là et eux
savent les échos qu'on en a du terrain
j'étais pas au congrès libéral ils m'ont
en fin de semaine mais ceux qui étaient
sur place me disait tout le monde tout
le monde est David c'est encore le
meilleur atout du parti oui il a une
certaine fatigue il traîne certains
boulets il est au gouvernement depuis 8
ans ce sera pas une campagne facile mais
est-ce que Freeland ferait mieux est-ce
que Mélanie jolie ferait mieux est-ce
que François Philippe champagne ferait
mieux Anita Hanane et ceux qu'on donc
pense à être dans la course à sa
succession ferait mieux la réponse c'est
non pas contre Pierre pollièvre qui va
probablement être un très redoutable
canin aussi alors on se dit ben on fonce
avec lui et d'ailleurs on a fait un
congrès autour de cette question là très
calme on a rien remis en question les
résolutions adoptées étaient plutôt
d'être plutôt bon bon on était pas dans
la remise en question des choix de
l'établissement du parti grosso modo on
lui a donné une table dans le dos puis
on lui dit quand tu seras prêt on sera
avec toi très bien vous êtes du même
avis Geneviève là-dessus puis je vais
passer au déficit zéro après la cible
difficile
sur le fait qu'il a dit à son monde je
serai votre capitaine la prochaine fois
là
moi et puis j'avais l'impression qu'il y
avait un soulagement moi j'y étais au
Congrès en fait semaine puis c'est ce
que je chantais auprès des délégués
c'est à dire on a pu se poser la
question on nous posera plus la question
à savoir ce qui verrait c'est ce qui
part la question est réglée puis
monsieur Trudeau et celui qui va nous
mener à la prochaine élection en même
temps j'ai pas senti qu'on partait en
érection demain matin je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec Alex et Monsieur
Trudeau performe bien lorsqu'il est en
mode électoral et il a montré samedi
soir c'était davantage un discours
électoral que nos types de discours mais
j'avais pas l'impression que Monsieur
Trudeau nous annonçait que demain matin
on allait en élection je serais très
surprise qu'on y aille en 2023 il
prépare ses troupes mais pour du très
long terme et même on n'a pas vu
vraiment de proposition on va parler des
propositions mais dans l'ensemble les
grandes nouvelles orientations du parti
ça a pas vraiment été débattu en fin de
semaine bon ben parlons-en d'une parce
que ça venait du Québec entre autres une
proposition pour
réduire un peu la cadence du cheval le
gouvernement en disant dépenser moins on
est inquiet pour les autres générations
et ça Alec ça a été battu autrement dit
d'ailleurs monsieur Trudeau a été élu un
peu en disant moi il est difficile de
zéro j'y crois pas beaucoup il continue
dans la même veine
ouais et on n'a pas senti que les
militaires avaient envie d'envoyer un
message à juste un Trudeau même si on en
parle souvent je parle souvent des
libéraux peut-être des plus vieux
libéraux de l'époque des gens chrétiens
Paul Martin qui sont pas très heureux de
voir qu'on a pas de discipline fiscale
qu'on devrait peut-être être capable de
faire davantage de choix les plus
centrices des libéraux sont un peu
confortables mais on a gagné les
dernières élections les deux trois
dernières élections chez les libéraux en
avalant idéologiquement le NPD sur sa
gauche en allant en ayant avec plusieurs
mesures qui étaient normalement
néo-démocrate et on n'a pas envie donc
de brasser ce que j'étais Trudeau a mis
en place dans les dernières années donc
on a voté contre par une faible marge
vous le dis mais on avait on sentait pas
le même pas voulu en débat vraiment il y
avait pas vraiment de gens qui étaient
sur le plancher pizza ça ça cette idée
là du retour à l'équilibre zéro je vais
en parler on sentait pas ça vraiment
chez les troupes libérales un peu parce
que la stratégie que les libéraux vont
mettre de la vape et on le centre
tranquillement là il teste leur ligne
c'est de vouloir détruire le Canada tel
qu'on le connaît ou allez vous couper ça
sera dans la CBC ça sera Radio-Canada ce
sera dans le programme de de soins
dentaire est-ce que ça sera dans les
garderies monsieur Poirier que vous
allez couper vous allez ramener les
femmes à la maison ça va être beaucoup
ça le discours sur l'identité canadienne
qu'on a construit chez les libéraux si
vous avez dans votre plateforme l'idée
de revenir à l'équilibre budgétaire
rapidement ben vous allez avoir une
plateforme qui ressemble à celle de
Pierre poignet à le discours
fonctionnera pas avec les chiffres alors
on a voulu donner à l'établissement
libéral aux organisateurs libéraux toute
la marge de
manœuvre même si on sent que c'est un
choix de certains là qu'on soit pas
capable d'avoir peut-être un ancrage
fiscal un peu plus solide mais je te
rappelle aussi Geneviève c'est militant
libéraux que c'est un doublant sur sa
gauche comment mulker dans une campagne
électorale où il partait derrière le NPD
que Justin Trudeau a réussi à reprendre
le pouvoir pour les libéraux en disant
moi difficile zéro j'y crois pas
monsieur le cas que c'était un peu
enfermé tu es tombé dans la trappe du
déficit de zéro et on a eu le résultat
qu'on a eu
oui mais c'est pas parce que ça a marché
7 ans que ça va marcher de l'an prochain
et Monsieur Trudeau devrait peut-être
regarder ce qui se passe en Ontario
parce que c'est ce que Catherine avait
fait elle avait doublée par sur la
gauche c'est exactement ça que c'est pas
ça en Ontario donc elle va doubler sur
la gauche le NPD avec gagner des
élections même minoritaires et ensuite
dans Ford est arrivé avec l'équilibre
budgétaire puis il y a gagné assez
facilement surtout la deuxième élection
et donc le passé est pas garant de
l'avenir mais très clairement on est
dans ce mode là au congrès libéral et on
l'a vu la journée où on a pas débattu
les propositions parce que j'ai pas eu
de débat mais la veille même c'est assez
renique parce que jean-chrétienne était
là pour faire un discours et il y a eu
beaucoup moins d'applaudissements
lorsqu'il a parlé des satiété
consécutives d'équilibre budgétaire que
c'était seulement les libéraux qui avait
accompli ça c'était lui effectivement et
les applaudissements étaient avaient été
beaucoup plus nourri lorsqu'on avait
lorsqu'il avait dit bah j'ai aussi fait
adopté la loi pour les mariages de
conjoint du même sexe
bien l'importance des initiatives de
gauche par rapport à celle plus au
centre de l'équilibre budgétaire
notamment et donc le Parti libéral
lui-même les troupes libérales puis il y
avait beaucoup de jeunes lors de ce
congrès là il y avait plus de 40 %,
c'était leur premier congrès 30 % de
jeunes aussi et donc les jeunes suivent
juste un Trudeau justement dans beaucoup
plus d'interventions que ce qu'on a eu
vu par le passé de la part du Parti
libéral là avant monsieur Trudeau c'est
quand même un personnage politique
complexe avec le bien dit on a
l'impression que ce qui le réveille ce
sont ces combats électoraux parfois
quand il est au pouvoir on a
l'impression que que c'est plus lent ou
plus pénible certaines prises de
décision est-ce que c'est la manière
dont enfin bref avoir ce sera ça sera
des livres je voulais parler de
l'initiative du siècle
100 millions de Canadiens en 2100 c'est
un peu le marketing autour de ça or ce
qui voudrait dire un million accueillir
un million d'immigrants au Canada à
terme et pour le Québec ça voudrait dire
accueillir plus de 112000 migrants
maintenant toutes les années je dis je
voulais parler de ça
il y a le tableau mais on en parle pas
parce que Christian va me tuer si j'en
parle sans lui il y a eu un pépin
technique on va en reparler demain mais
peut-être un seul mot je vais pas ouvrir
le débat avec vous un seul mot là-dessus
puis je vais vous parler après de Marc
Lalande mais un mot Alec il y a du
marketing là dedans là il y a une
volonté
de redéfinir le Canada mais il y a du
marketing aussi
oui il y en a beaucoup est-ce que le
Canada va tenir la même ligne sur les
migrations dans les 80 prochaines années
c'est là en 80 ans on verra bien si
chacun des gouvernements qui se
succèdent va remplir ses promesses va
garder le cap on verra ça veut pas dire
que éventuellement il y aura pas qu'il a
un changement de position un changement
de décision forcé par la réalité des
choses créer du logement par exemple un
moment donné il faudra se poser des
questions sur ce qu'on est capable de
loger tout ce monde-là donc on verra
bien mais je voulais juste dire
rapidement que ça veut pas dire que
parce que le fédéral veut aller là le
Québec est obligé de suivre sur le
Québec ne suit pas parce qu'il fait que
ses propres règles ça va vous ça
voudrait dire une perte d'influence du
Québec dans le Canada l'un est
incompatible avec l'autre on peut pas
augmenter les seuils d'immigration au
Canada et ne pas les bijoux que les
bougies au Québec sans perdre
l'influence à Ottawa ça éventuellement à
moyen long terme faudra se poser des
questions là-dessus il y a le choc que
Geneviève de deux façons de voir
ce pays là c'est clair une minute là
dessus je un peu un troisième choc qui
passe toujours sous silence mais qui à
mon avis est majeur c'est la question de
la croissance économique il y a 100 ans
il y a 200 ans et lorsqu'on parlait de
croissance économique oui il y avait de
la place pour tout le monde il y avait
des ressources on parlait pas de
changement climatique puis
d'environnement là ça a changé la donne
on se rend compte qu'on a atteint un peu
la capacité 300 puisqu'il va venir faire
la suite et pas toujours réjouissant et
pour les nouvelles générations les
jeunes générations les changements
climatiques il va falloir y penser et
les économies économistes commencent à
parler de décroissance l'économie de la
décroissance comment est-ce qu'on gère
ça mais évidemment si on est accès vers
la croissance la croissance tout azimute
comme semble vouloir le dire le Benoit
fédéral est-ce qu'on s'en fait pas
fausse route par ailleurs parce qu'on
devrait pas avoir un débat justement sur
c'est quoi la croissance puisque pas
moyen de voir les choses autrement
est-ce que c'est juste en ayant plus de
main d'oeuvre qu'on va régler tous les
problèmes on parle les hôpitaux de
l'éducation les pensions et tout ça donc
essayons de réfléchir autrement puis on
a l'impression qu'on a pas si ça se
passe là pour faire cette réflexion
et parce que le débat oui c'est ça
j'aurais dû le dire c'est un dossier de
Journal de Montréal c'est une question
dont on avait parlé lors de la dernière
campagne électorale on demandait à
monsieur Legault poursuivre le rythme
canadien de vous prêt accueillir 100000
évidemment la réponse est non il y a
aucun parti politique au Québec qui qui
va jusqu'à un seuil de 100000 le Québec
solidaire c'est 80 mais bref
on va reparler donc on va en reparler
cette semaine un mot marque Lalonde avec
qui nous a quitté il y a deux jours Marc
Lalonde qui était qui était une des
éminences grises de Trudeau pair
ouais on a beaucoup parlé des Trois
Colombes à Ottawa au milieu des années
60 en Pierre Elliot Trudeau est arrivé
avec Jean Marchand et Gérard Pelletier
en réalité on aurait dû parler des
quatre mousquetaires parce que Marc
lalalon était probablement le quatrième
un peu comme d'Artagnan il est arrivé
sur le tard qui fait pas partie des
Trois Mousquetaires c'est le 4e mais en
réalité il était aussi important que les
trois autres d'abord comme conseiller de
Trudeau donc dans l'ombre son chef de
cabinet mais joue un rôle important
ensuite qui a été élu une fois qui a été
élu à eu des gros portefeuilles
portefeuille important au moment des
négociations constitutionnelles entre
autres mais aussi ressources naturelles
gros débat au Canada qui l'est encore
aujourd'hui mais qu'il était aussi à
l'époque la crise du pétrole à l'époque
dans les années 70 donc un joueur très
très important qui est dans l'histoire
canadienne qui est avec les trois autres
que j'ai nommés probablement faisait
partie du French power ce qu'on appelle
French power à l'époque la prise de
contrôle des Québécois du gouvernement
fédéral lui il était dans les dans les
importants du French power même s'il y a
pas été associé toujours aussi
droitement que ce que les achats que les
trois autres
Paul dans la presse ce matin a créé un
beau texte c'est d'ici aussi la
génération de politiciens qui allait au
bout de leur conviction même si il
savait que c'était pas dans le vent on
peut dire qu'il a pris du vent le vent
de face à quelques reprises monsieur
Lalonde Geneviève
oui puis je pense que une de ces
principaux combats c'était justement la
question nationale le fédéralisme et
donc c'était quelqu'un qui réfléchissait
avec Pierre et le Trudeau sur justement
c'est quoi le fédéralisme canadien la
place du Québec et comment répondre au
revendications nationaliste séparative
de la province et donc ça je pense que
ça a été une contribution importante
aussi de la part de Marc Lalande qu'il
faudrait pas négliger ironiquement si on
décèces survient au même moment où
Monsieur chrétien en fait une apparition
au parti libérales c'est quand même
important l'apparition de ce chrétiens
en fin de semaine parce que
rappelez-vous monsieur de Trudeau
j'étais Trudeau avec quand même fait de
campagne en faisant table rase sur l'air
chrétien et donc on voit deux
personnages à cette époque-là sur
certains
Geneviève Alec Christian
à vous deux pour parlera de l'initiative
du sexe cette semaine avec Christian
merci